bitcoin and cryptocurrency they're not
going to zero and they're not going away
there's a brand new opinion piece in the
washington post by sebastian malaby and
he lays out three specific reasons why
you should have confidence that crypto
will rise again he states that first new
technologies generate investor
excitement as intended they should but
precisely because the tech is new
investors cannot gauge how much
excitement is warranted and of course
booms and busts inevitably follow the
second point that sebastian makes is
that these boom and bust cycles can't
tell you much about whether a technology
will triumph investors bet on things
they hope might work but the nature of
early stage tech bets is that a majority
of ventures go to zero during the
upcycle soaring valuations are no
guarantee of success and on the way down
plunging share prices are equally poor
signals
lastly sebastian points out that
innovation and profit are not reliably
connected trains bicycles and e-commerce
we're all genuine innovations but many
early pioneers went bankrupt conversely
google and facebook were not the
inventors of internet search and social
media yet they captured nearly all the
value in these categories in similar
fashion some of today's crypto
innovators will go bust but they could
point the way for others now i think
sebastian's got a great point here that
innovation is obviously happening
whether it's in bitcoin or other sectors
of the crypto industry but what we do
have to still wonder is who will capture
the value where will the profits flow
either way whether you think it's the
current crop of entrepreneurs and
innovators or it's one class to come
it's very obvious that this technology
is superior to previous attempts in the
financial industry and around fiat
currencies and so the idea that it's
going away that it's going to zero as an
industry is just absurd bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they're here to stay
there's over 150 million people who have
adopted the technology they're not going
to give it up
and so ultimately as investors the
challenge is to navigate the future
markets trying to find out not just who
the innovators are not just who's
actually building products that people
find valuable but trying to understand
where value will accrue and where those
profits will flow as sebastian so
eloquently pointed out if you go back
and you look at history over and over
and over again innovative areas have
boom and bust cycles we've seen this
play out over and over again in the
bitcoin ecosystem as well
and this time is probably not different
it's likely to recover and so being able
to be a long-term thinker not get caught
up in the short-term price volatility is
a superpower when you're dealing with
innovative areas with high volatility to
the prices that are associated with
sebastian nails it bitcoin and crypto
will rise again it's just a question of
who's going to be around who's going to
have done the work in the bear market to
actually capture that value and where
will investors have made their bets
time will tell who's making good
decisions right now and who is not